walking into a storm the chancellor
arriving in Washington today for
meetings at the international monetary
fund what happens after Friday when the
bank
buying bonds what's about it for the
governor it's a matter for the governor
but the governor of the bank of England
says it's now up to investors to get
their houses in order before Friday
you've got three days left now you've
got to get this done those words
resounding through financial markets
back in the UK sending the pound
tumbling but these are just the latest
lurches on a roller coaster Journey no
one is particularly enjoying
and for the UK at least these bumps were
exacerbated by Mr quaten's mini budget
which says the fund's chief Economist
complicated matters for the bank it was
the sense that the budget as it was
announced was suggesting a very
stimulative effect in the short run and
something that would have complicated uh
matters for the bank of England's
efforts to bring down inflation and so
that's something that you know again the
details are now coming going to be
coming out in a few weeks we look
forward to that discussion the clock in
other words it's ticking both for the
chancellor and for markets because one
thing we've learned is that billions of
pounds of pension scheme money was
invested in funds which was simply not
equipped to deal with these kinds of
Market lurchers
I think that a lot of people outside the
pensions worlds have been quite
surprised to find that so much kind of
debt if you like has been accumulated by
Pension funds so having a real problem
in the Government Bond Market has the
potential to spill over into insurance
company problems or Bank problems and
while I don't want to be kind of
alarmist about this there is a risk of
contagion into all sorts of financial
assets and real economy assets like
houses and the like so the bond market
is actually very important
that brings us back to the governor's
comments following the many budgets the
bank offered emergency support to the
bond market but that's due to expire on
Friday will they change their mind no
one knows it's a game of financial
chicken
but the bank is playing tough shortly
after the governor's comments it issued
a statement saying it is important that
lessons are learned from this episode
but this is not just a game those Bond
rates determine the rates we pay on our
mortgages with two-year fixed rate
mortgages now up above 6.4 percent those
taking out the loans face the biggest
mortgage burden since the late 80s last
time around that led to a housing crash
this time
well one day at a time Ed Conway Sky
News